it's Tuesday the 24th of October the
checkin is brought to you by Babel
listen it's a new year I know who cares
but you can make a resolution whenever
you want this fall instead of jumping up
and down with your friends on
Sundays try learning a new language they
have quick 10 minute lessons so you
won't get board you'll be able to start
speaking a new language in as little as
three weeks so you can send sound smart
at the Christmas party okay listen I
know you only got a GED but this is easy
okay you want to learn another language
it's important why because it's kind of
analytical at no listen you're never too
old to learn Chinese I'm thinking about
it right now I got to take time I gotta
hang out with Lee you know how it goes
but anyway bab lessons are designed by
over 150 language at experts so you're
getting the real deal one study even
found that using Babel for but just 15
hours was the same as taking a full
semester of a college language course
where you going to get that you just
sitting there at home like a moo
anyway so do me a favor here's the
special limited time only listen you got
a nephew you got a cousin you know he's
having a hard time boom get him a Babel
subscription I'm Gonna Get You 55% off
what are you talking about 55% off
anybody can give you 50 Babel wants you
to learn a language they know what's to
come down but only for our listeners at
babel.com
joeey Joe y That's 55% off at
b. Joey I've been telling people for
years you got to learn two or three
languages I know like eight languages
all right I used to be a Cuban James
Bond anyway babel.com
Joey let's get this party started Jack
I'm out of
candles turn off your TVs run for your
life
it's over they didn't put you on this
planet just to give up if Uncle Joey
could do it I could rule the world I you
got to be thinking welcome back to
[Music]
show there you go you should have
planned ahead there you go now you know
how I feel I called him two times the
game was on fire the Philly game two
times you're watching the game nothing
now I'm about this is what they this is
my life this is my life that's
why sometimes I gotta be careful when I
call people because I already know
they're not gonna call back till I'm
about to take a sit and watch a
game I just went and got an Italian ice
I just sat down with the spoon never get
the Italian ice you sit down and you
forget I don't have a spoon now you
gotta go back upstairs
come down I put the Italian ice
in my pocket I have a hooded sweatshirt
on in my basement I put an Italian ice
in my pocket and let it melt for like
eight or nine minutes then I take that
out one of those old school
Goos from shop right and I scrape I
about I'm about to put the spoon in
those eight minutes it's like waiting
for a judge you're like what the
am I doing with my life those eight
minutes I got an Italian ice in my
pocket I've been doe since 8 morning
it's 9:01 at night it's Miller time now
as soon as I sit down to watch whatever
the is when they want to call me
back and my phone will ring four times
in a row from four different people
three of them I called last Tuesday so I
want to hear from them I want to get
raped you understand me I don't
want to hear from people now I forgot
what I even called you for that
was last week forget about it you're
done it's a whole new P start
from scretch
what I I legit have this written down I
have this written down and I don't know
if we're started or not but I have I
want to talk to you and it doesn't to be
about all of them but about like Joey
Diaz's Like rules or laws because you
have rules that no one else has and I
have telephone written down listen let
me talk to you this way all right it's
not even rules is it's basic
salesmanship
sometimes like just basic 101 if I call
you and I tell you my story and I go as
soon as I hear from them I'll call you
and I don't hear from them for two weeks
because I'm dealing with
corporate and it's two weeks and
every day you're like I'm available
today actual while either I'm gonna stab
myself I'm gonna go down there and stab
you you know what I'm saying especially
when my head's somewhere completely
different like I'm talking I got a book
thing on Wednesday night I got 20,000
things my daughter's coming home at 308
and you want to call me at 301 and talk
me you just cracked me I had another guy
today as I'm getting ready to go to
Jiu-Jitsu hey you want to go to lunch on
Friday at nah it's got to be after 1
right I go it's got to be after 1 I want
to go to Jiu-Jitsu on Friday from 12:00
to 12:45 and then sometimes I stay the
younger guys beat me up I sit there I
talk with those guys that's my
social that's my life I'm 60 I'm old you
know what I'm saying yeah I come home
and sometimes I get home at 2 Le
sometimes I get home at
1:30 sometimes I get home at a quarter
to three I hang with those guys they're
great guys so now he's like I said to
him we'll have to do it Friday now it's
Monday morning all right my head's
somewhere completely different Friday is
not even in my schem the only thing I
know about Friday is I got Friday night
off my daughter's going to a movie and
my wife's got the draft she's coaching
basketball this year that's all I know
so Friday night I got off right that's
all I know right now Thursday I got
something Sunday
night no yeah Sunday night I got
something I'm supposed to go to but now
the more I think about it doesn't look
like I gotta go it's one of those things
where I gotta Park and walk you lost me
already this is not most things huh
isn't that most things in places much
that's theel already
to park and walk valet park and this
place is huge that means I'm there for
an hour unprotected outside with
Momo going aren't you the guy from The
Sopranos I need this right now Lee I
could be at home watching Sunday Night
Football about to watch an episode of
some repeat on Netflix or some
but the funny thing is is like you
have all these
schedules and and rules but you don't
tell me like like these guys are just
calling you and it like it's just a rule
that you can't break like how do do you
do you teach people your rules like do
you train
people I got my own personal problems
everybody got their own personal demons
you know what I'm saying I like to do
a certain way you know uh
everything is slowed down in my life
right now like people hit me up do you
want to do a podcast what time 12
o'clock in this city you lost me
gota be 11 o'clock you
know because I want to be done at
by 12:30 so I could be on the
ferry to Rudies get a bowl of clam CH a
soup maybe some Calamar with medium
sauce and then getting that I95
whatever it is hit the Parkway
South and next thing you know I'm
passing that strip club on the on the
right next to a dery queen only in
Jersey is there a strip club next to a
da Queen and let me tell you
something the girls must be spending
their whole day there because
all of them are chubby like me they're
outside all day drinking milkshake
cigarettes every time I drive by there's
traffic so I look over just to see what
the girls are doing what's the flavor of
the day one day it's a slushy one day
it's a you know hey strip is
like ice cream too you know what I'm
saying is it really like a chubby strip
club or the I don't even know Lee but
they don't I don't know it's a weird
strip club I've never gone in there I
went to the one about three miles away
one my buddies that I grew up with when
I first moved here but they shut it down
now they just
reopen why did they shut it
down illegal charges you know these
people you know they're
victims and it's it's in a town that's
very
conservative and the strip club that my
buddies had think about if I own the
strip club and I 60 years old and I
wasn't married and I was still doing
blow are you kidding me me I'd
be you'd find me dead at this strip club
sweaty I'd have like blood coming out of
my nose the sweat dripping all over me
my shirt open some chick took my chain
that that was my end but this you know a
jersey strip club to us it's still
1980 are there still partying in there
it's not the party it's I think it's Bob
B that's the only way they could have
stayed open they could have been nude
okay but you know where we grew up in in
the ear 80s I told you about that bar
that we saw so in our minds if we open
up a strip club we kind of wanted to be
like
that and he had a listen in our
day it would have been a tremendous
strip club I went there I would come
back from North Burgen and I'd stop in
there to say hello to him and his son
great
family met some Cuban girls in there
that were great ladies they were
telling me about Cuba they were going
back and forth you didn't you know I
just give them a couple cple dollars and
they talk to me for 10 minutes so what
you know what I'm saying people pay me
to talk for me to talk for an hour
and they sit there and they want to take
a picture I can't give a
stripper a couple old wrinkle
singles with crack on them from 1982 and
soon as they touch it their
fingernails disintegrate from the
real ether in that anyway
what we talking about Jesus about trip
like have you ever done because I was
saying I did I've done Les shows but
I've never done like at a strip club
have you ever performed at a strip
club yes what is that like brutal I can
imagine I think I did it twice in Denver
there was when I was first starting like
four years
in a new strip club had opened it wasn't
uh Shotgun Willies or any of the
well-known ones this one was like a
cabaret in Denver and when it opened
they would pay Headliners one 75 and
features a buck and a quarter for 30
minutes in the strip club and they would
give you a steak it was one of
those type of strip clubs it was real I
forget the name of it I don't even know
if it St still this is
1995 and it was tremendous it was a
high-end thg I was getting 125 I was
running out of there with the full 125
in those days I was not GNA sit around
for a lap dance I broke in those days I
was delivering Chinese food to
make ends meet you know there was no way
I would take that check and run
the out of that I would take the
steak to go I think I only worked it
twice and then years later when I got to
The Comedy Store some guy came up to me
at the store and he goes I'd like you to
work some functions for
me Fairfax and Santa
Monica you headed down from sunset's
trip you head it down to Santa Monica on
Fairfax you hook a right and you
go down about three blocks and on the
left is a Mexican joint I took you one
time they have burritos we used to
always go for chicken burritos when I
first got to the store in 97 there's a
7-Eleven next to it and across the
street there's an acting studio okay
across the street from that is a still
it's still there I think they jump up
and down with motorcycle suits
in there now but at this time it was uh
a cabaret where you
gambled you Gam LED and you
uh pilot to bombarder you gambled and
you you gambled and you also there was a
belet
show you know it wasn't uh
nudity it was a very high-end it was
like an after hours type thing the show
started like at midnight I did it once
it wasn't for me listen if you're not
going to take off your clothes why am I
here you know what I'm saying that time
I was single it was 98 I'm at the store
doing powder the gig paid 40 bucks but
we didn't go on till 2 in the morning
Lee what you had to watch after the
burlesque show now if you're doing
cocaine playing
poker do you want to see me up there
doing stupid jokes at 2:30 in
the morning me it was like me Josh Wolf
maybe Sam
trip and every week with somebody else
and I did it like maybe once twice the
reason I remember is because Shawn Penn
was there one night playing poker that's
the highlight of my strip club
career it's a tough job it's
like uh living in New York state and
doing casinos on a Tuesday night you
know comedy's more popular now but when
in 19 in 2000 I would do casinos on
Tuesday that paid you cash but
Lee oh my God you felt like Jesus in
front of the je before they I
him you felt like you were pleading for
your life first off there was
there and there was a guy with a
stopwatch listen I got off one time at
28 minutes this guy sat me down for an
hour all right so I like because I I'm
like nobody could stand there you're
just talking to yourself like a crazy
man I'm dead serious you know
when you're an open micer and a beginner
you're like yay I can't work to work a
casino and then you go to
there's a
casino outside of Vegas not Laughlin and
not anything else this is close to the
Idaho border border Triple B books a two
week run in there it's the biggest Money
Maker he's got they pay you like a
hundred a night six nights but you have
to stay for two weeks I tapped out after
four nights
like I gotta I did like Monday Tuesday
Wednesday and by Thursday I was back at
the underground you quit Grand
died you know I told him some story oh
my
God that's ship started to bail and then
about three months later he gave me
another chance and I just bailed and
after that we talked every once in a
while but there was no
get I bailed on a Thursday
morning D I bailed A couple
times
sometimes you just got to abandon ship
this is a not a good ship to be
on I what you like during mid week you
just be like no thanks no listen why are
we doing this you got all kids band
coming in here 11 I'm up there talking
about putting dynamite in the chick's
this just ain't right somebody's
losing out
here they're just sitting there staring
at you you know they from like
uh you
know Washington or something you know
when you're doing comedy out there oh my
God sometimes you're like why am I doing
this you know 10 minutes before the show
you got a fact that says you gotta be
clean because they're Mormons I got to
switch up my I can't even do a bacon
joke I got to do a joke about having 18
Mistresses and you know going to
[Laughter]
church are you so in your mind
as a young comic you have all these I
can't wait to work in Casino until they
give you a full week and you see what
life is all about when you're performing
for people with two hoses in
their nose and they got like an alert in
their hand ready to go they ready to go
a wheelchair and there's some
nephew like come on Grandpa hold on 10
more minutes and I get 20 more per of
the will I mean it's it's just
so up the listen one of my
biggest things I ever wanted to
do when I came back here in 93 was to do
something at Atlantic
City okay it was my dream
Lee but Hometown yeah not my
Hometown well Hometown like Vegas it's
like it's like I it's a cool venue or a
cool area so yeah yeah until you get
mugged right was the last time you went
to AC you gotta leave that you gotta
leave that building with 22
armed guards if you win Jesus after
o'clock you see people you've never seen
before seen people you've never seen
before I was down there twice since I've
been back here in two
years wo you better stay in that hotel
and you better bring your own lock for
the door you know what I'm saying you
don't trust nobody down there and they
got nice hotels they got kickass
restaurants but I don't know I just
haven't felt safe down there like all
day Saturday I didn't leave my room
that's
crazy I I would have thought it would
have been okay the beach is the
beach is okay it's colder than you
could smell bodies there from
Boardwalk Empire in 1942 and so
I don't know but the feeling when I
stepped on stage there was superb I
opened up for Rogan oh recently right no
this is two years ago okay yeah well
that's what I meant I did seven minutes
and I ran the out of there two
nights in a
row Rogan just wanted to see me and I
wanted to see him so he's like come on
down if you want to get on stage if not
I pay you I'm like he just got the
Spotify you know he was like
always great to me so and we just just
hung out for two days and crack jokes
right after Saturday night I abandoned
and I talked him into leaving too
cuz I asked him when are you leaving and
he's like I'm leaving Sunday morning I
go time up why what are you doing with
the Spotify
Gus people tell them you want to get out
of here at 11 o'clock he's like that's a
good idea boom he was out of there at 11
o'clock are you f you give me 100 Mil to
do a gig in Atlantic City I got a
helicopter as soon as I get on stage you
know how we do it either you come or
you're gonna get stuck
there once I go like this and I look
that way and I'm headed to that curtain
you're done it's curtains kaput and
they're trying to talk to me thank you
sign the frame yeah good and you're down
in that and they take you away like
get smart that's what I used to be not
not afraid but I like I knew if I like
we went to a club or somewhere and I
wasn't there when you ready like ready
to go I'd be finding a new way home like
I like you you used to aim the car out
you used to just tip people and leave
cars in like places where like
definitely not supposed to leave a car
leave the car right there don't worry
about nothing if they give you a ticket
tell them I'll be out here with go
inside and get me I got a neck bracing
the
trunk and like H have you left anyone
before left what left someone at a place
like if they weren't ready
oh oh you have no idea there's a friend
of mine I grew up with and on the Judas
Priest solar whatever tour we went to
some theater in New York we went to
maybe uh I forget the name of the
theater it doesn't really matter it's
not there
anymore and one of them my friend went
like it was a buddy of mine came to me
he goes she's going to the concert with
another friend of mine if you're there
can you keep your eye on him and I said
absolutely I reached out to them I go if
you guys feel safer this guy's coming
this guy's coming we all grew up
together they got cocktails they got
Quaaludes you know whatever
right we get over the Judas Priest we
all walk in to the orchestra together
and they're sitting close to us they got
tickets like they're like an eighth row
we like in seventh
row and I don't know what the
happened like it was like I don't even
know who went up first it was like Iron
Maiden and I look over there and they're
Bol over there rocking but one of their
friends came like from in some
other high school or somebody's cousin
you know how it goes right well guess
who got sick the cousin she
started puking in the AIS so right away
I don't know nobody
right I don't know nobody I never seen
these crazy animals
before and something happens they took
the girl in the bathroom now you know
listen I got to the point I was going to
so many concerts at that time it
was like it was the summertime we were
always going somewhere I was a little
burnt out and I'm like you know what I
heard what I came to
he it's time for sh so I the opening act
no I watched ion Maiden okay now one
thing I hate is since I'm a kid is
leaving when everybody else is
leaving okay now I gotta leave here with
3,000 people I was wor I was worried
about Co before coid like I got to leave
here with 3,000 people this is New York
City breathing on my neck
I'd rather walk out of here than have to
crawl out right so I walk up to them
they come back with pukey she's
like you know and I go guys this is no I
go let's get her out of
here right and all of a sudden like they
carrying her out I'm trying to help her
and she just pukes again like the
Exorcist and that was my stage call
Abandoned Ship I just put my roller
skates on and boogied out of there I
walked to the train and I went home I
had other friends there from my hometown
it's not like I left him there and like
days of you actually carrying her and
dropping her listen my mother had just
died you think I'm worried about
leaving you I got bigger things in my
mind I gotta go check the grave to see
if she's still alive I don't
know I'm gonna go wait be all
night when you bring pukey it was
supposed to be us that's why you're not
supposed to show up with somebody unless
you know their family now I
gotta worry about
pukey until this say one of the girls
when I see you now right he says you
you left me at that Judas
Priest
concert love it we we had it's
funny that you said like you don't want
to leave with everyone else I went to I
got invited to a UFC one time with you
and it was like the only time I went it
was great seats and like I think it was
like at the beginning of the like the
main event you're like it's time to get
time to
go we watch it on the TVs by like the
concessions
yeah we went up to the TV by the
concession stand there's not a soul up
there you could light yourself
on fire and die and nobody would even
notice it's a it's the main card nobody
gives a you know like that movie
with uh the guys and they rob Boston
Stadium oh yeah um with Affleck yeah
yeah what's the name of that movie God
damn it the town no the town yes the
town I'm sorry
let me tell you something for your
aspiring screenwriters that's the next
flick they've already done 22
o oceans 28 ocean these guys are
100 years old and they're still robbing
I'm 60 I couldn't crawl out a window are
these guys going
into I love burglar Horizon houses if I
could still do it I'd still be out there
banging it out but you got cameras and I
ain't going to fit no closet no
more you know you can hide under a bed
when you're
140 180 but once you're busting 250 290
that's going to be a wobble that looks
like a that looks like a seesaw
you know what I'm saying that's it those
days are over with so I don't get it so
right now if you're an aspiring riter
you put together a nice script
an indie script about robbing a
UFC event in a in a different type of
town not Las Vegas like in a a town like
that where they have it's a huge gate
you know do a show in Idaho or
somewhere like that that's more you
bring some good Fighters you're
going to get people over from Canada
blah blah and they're coming over with
real cash they don't give a if they
go to ticket vendors and buy $2,000 I've
seen it there's a big difference of a
UFC event in Vegas than a UFC event
anywhere else and in La they show up
late you know right down you go to UFC
in Minneapolis they're there at
401 hanging on the door punch in each
other let banging people's head doing
double takedowns and it's real you
know it's this is what they have on a
Saturday they work three months
to stay in a hotel have tequila do
mushrooms bring the wife you know this
is a big thing so it's a big difference
but a guy robbing like a
UFC when the main fight is going
on the time to do it how many times I
set up there by
myself and I'm like there ain't a soul
up here and every all the vendors they
all got their little brooms what do you
think they're doing they're in the
hallways watching the
fight listen I'm not here
telling you about a
scam a script you know what I'm saying
if you rob Vegas and you get caught
don't put my name into it
Tuckers before you wreck
yourself holy do you do that when
you're walking around you like this
would be a good place
to or no
sometimes sometimes I'm walking around
like look at here a purse you know and
she's with this kid 40 yards away on the
seaa rob it out of principal you know
what I'm saying how do you have a person
and you put it by a rock there and
you're a away any budy will take
it you deserve to get robbed but me I'm
a Good Samaritan I stay in the area
until she comes over and make sure
nobody robs the
purse that is very nice of you
you gotta do it it's good Jesus is
watching you
know always watching
today holy that was fun
it's
uh you were talking you were talking
about like the difference of like the
UFC
audiences and I went to two I went to
both nights of
shapel and it was it was great like the
it was fun to see but the audiences were
very like the shows were almost
completely different both night like the
Thursday versus the Friday three hours
of material D well no no his I'm sorry
his material was was fairly similar but
I'm saying like the audience and like
the reaction to the material was
different Thursday and Friday like it
was like and it was very similar
material and it was just like the
audiences were very different it it was
a it was just strange to see and you
it's the same guy the same comic but he
has like almost two different
audiences you went Thursday and
Friday Thursday night was the alleged
incident I he said in the article I read
it said he said he denied being in
Boston on Thursday which I thought was
hysterical I'm telling you everybody's
Oceans 11 they don't know
nothing but you know it was H it was an
strange thing I didn't the Articles made
it seem worse than I thought it was I
mean with 20,000 people there yeah
you're going to get people who are going
to get upset I didn't see anyone
leave
and
I I'm we're never going to get into
political stuff but to me it was pretty
down the middle it it was like if you're
if you're either way on one side you're
going to either love it or hate it what
are you Bruce buffing now I don't know
what do you mean I understand I'm just
goof oh no okay um it was just I didn't
view it as hateful either way but it was
not as
pro Israel as I think a lot of
people either would like or or expect um
but it wasn't that much of the
show and it was
cool I was just more impressed with with
like him and I thought the show like it
just you're talking about like the
energy like the with the DJ you were
very impressed with the DJ I was very
impress show in Arena Dave is a
genius to that sounds yeah you pay 300
bucks to see Dave it's worth every do
I'm GNA tell you why it's not just three
jerk offs coming out telling you
stupid jokes it's a
experience you don't know what you're
gonna get which is a concept that I love
that's the old Rolling Stones you didn't
know who the was going to show
up for a for a fan that's a great
experience if I go to a show and it's
him Donell Ali Wong you saw uh Dean Dane
Cook uh you know Ahmed Muhammad uh and
then he puts on like the DJ that night
could be DJ khed you don't know
till you get there and he'll have a rap
group that is dropping and he'll come
out with them and around and you
know what at the end of the day it's not
just a comedy show it's an
experience and I think people enjoy that
if I'm a consumer yeah that $400 ticket
but guess what you're going to be stoned
as nobody's going to say to
you you could eat mushrooms you could
jump up and down and You're gonna laugh
with Dave and his cohorts and
you know what man it's a great show the
energy listen when you go into a UFC the
first thing you
feel is the energy yeah but Joey I could
watch it at home I understand you don't
see me jumping up and down at UFC's you
know why cuz you got a park and got to
walk that's
it all right and when I'm home all I got
to do is walk to the refrigerator or the
toilet right that's it but I
can't deny that to you when you walk
into to a
UFC I go to basketball games I go to
baseball games I love every minute of it
but again the UFC took it up a
notch you know when you don't know who's
going to show up at any UFC so as a fan
you you're at a UFC see in Tokyo
and Jared Leo sitting there dressed up
like James Bond you have an experience I
went home Jared Leo was there Usman
knocked out the Russian I know he didn't
but whatever the story is and that's a
that's something that's a you know Burke
ker is building is an experience what
he's doing I I love what he's
doing whatever you have to say
about bur ker he just he's the new
Walking Dead
except with acid and whatever it's a
bunch of dude drinking
titos okay that's it and he puts on the
best ax and he goes to little stadiums
to give love to everybody who's
better than that uh I Gotta Give Love to
skank Fest look what they have
done that's an experience you get to
throw King condom around there's
a wrestling match people are fighting
Ari's naked you know that's a
experience if you've got that
stamina yeah and people do that's in
that's deep so I give those
all the credit in the
world all the credit in the world
everybody freaks out I went to a club
last night these have been
partying for three days that three
they're 22 in a
room they're young kids they're saving
money there's 22 of them in the room
they drove there with a full
tank of gas one of them's got a
warrant that's what life is all about my
friend think about sucker and I was
thinking about that too
because I always appreciated when people
come to shows but
like I I saw Chappelle like 10 something
15 years ago and it was like it's an
event like those kind of shows are like
things people will remember their whole
life they if they remember one thing
from it like there's like a good chance
going to see Chappelle at the guard like
like there's something people will
remember and it's just
uh to put in perspective for like
someone like me is was like crazy to put
more emphasis on it almost you know what
I remember when I walked in Boston
Garden 20 years ago what's that
98 one of those Comics brought me we
were doing that club downtown in the
football shape Stadium I was a feature
act it was a Monday night or some
and he said if I if I didn't mind
stopping and doing a room he had an
extra TI for Boston on Tuesday night
right there just if you know anything
about me my heart stop I'm like here I
got $8 in my pocket I hope I don't have
to buy drinks and this guy's like nah I
got tickets that everything is included
wo you know and then I just brought
reefer with me but you know what I first
remember when I walk into to Boston
Garden whether it's new old go back to
98 and 99 or something I remember when I
saw all those flags all the ship things
you know you look at that and you're
like that's America Jack
whatever you want to call him that's
that's old school that's when I was
growing up all that was happening
as I got into basketball and then in my
hometown there was a disciple that was a
cousin to
Hab and he play on the Street Glenn Hab
yeah in fact they were two cousins and
and one of them played on the state
championship North Bergen team in 1978
when they won the states and then there
was a younger brother and he was a year
older than me and I remember I was in
awe that he was a H cheat like I
never tried to foul him like like
that if he called a foul I just didn't
argue with him he was a hav Lee
you know you want me to blow
smoke and we
had I forget their names but we had two
the O'Neal Brothers remember I used to
talk about the O'Neal Brothers the two
Irish twins that you hit one and the
other one would cry oh yeah we play
basketball hours karate
Cho they live next to somebody who was a
cousin to the Celtic and the guy would
come over there and we would beg him
whenever he comes the guy was
like a third string Center he was a
skinny white dude from like Jersey I
forget what the his name was and uh
we would always tell cousin bring him
over we want to meet him you know he was
a nobody but we didn't give a he
was a
Celtic so it was like you know I never
got to M him or anything but anyway who
gives a but that's what I got so
half of those places when you walk in
you get sucked in by the energy if
you're I don't give a if you're a
Yankee fan and somebody invites you into
to see a Red Sox game and you
walk in there if you're a Yankee fan
true fan of baseball
you'll look around and go wow why did I
pay $800 for these seats my ass don't
even fit this
Irish puke I could smell it
everywhere yeah know my wife's got to
sit on my lap she's tipping the scale at
two10 since she had the
kid we're just having fun duck duckers
it's Tuesday the 24th don't forget
Wednesday the 25th tomorrow night I'm in
Brick New
Jersey at Barnes & Noble brick uh 6 to8
I'll be there giving out some books and
I'm thinking of raffling something so
I'm gonna go to Hobby Lobby tomorrow and
get some raffle tickets hopefully they
got there I'll be printing some
counterfeit ones or something I can't
tell you what color they are because I
don't want this jersey dog you let if
you have a raffle on a Tuesday and a
Wednesday and you put out pink
things by the time you get that
Wednesday everybody's got a pink ticket
you get there you're like H how do all
these people win because you put the
same color it's like when you're on
probation you got to call to see what
color it is when I was on probation
years ago for I was like Color
Purple so Monday Wednesdays and Friday
you had a call in like 1 800 I'm
on probation you put your code in and
they go it's Monday the 23rd of October
today the colors are red and by the time
they was dropping knowledge joh you'd be
holding your breath red green and aqua
talk to you on Wednesday and youd hang
up and go oh I don't have to drink any
more apple cider vinegar
everything else I drank the last 24
hours to beat this piss ass I did it
again they but they have something they
catch you eventually they always catch
you but who gives a who's a
criminal that watches this show nobody
we're all in the up and up up we're
trying to make our lives better we're
just two fat that get high on a
Monday Tuesday get together you know
there's a great game on Philadelphia
against Arizona there's another one in
an hour for the AC it's Houston
against Texas in Houston forget
about it you understand me 20 life no
parole now I haven't been watching
baseball is this if Philly wins tonight
they win the World Series no no no I
think they have to play tomorrow and
then they have to play the winner of the
Texas Houston game oh because I I all I
saw to it was they were uh oiling up the
light posts today in
Philly see they shouldn't be doing that
that's what you know what happened
before you know what I put like this is
my just this is the way Uncle Joey
thinks you want to know how I think you
want to know the rules I got I got the
best playing basketball last year when
you went to see him was the center from
Philly and guys I went three times I
went to three games last season my
heart's always in Philly I always go to
Philly you know why because I could be
myself if I want to scratch my balls I
scratch my balls if I want to jump up
and down I jump up and down and yell
Mercy my daughter adores it
because people go off and she giggles
her and Florentine young man we
we take kids with us they go
crazy because you hear all these cursed
words and you hear that's out of
this world so I feel comfortable in
Philly everybody out the stadium
everybody's quiet if you say something
they all look at you like you
know I can't I just pay three bills for
this ticket I gotta sit here
like I ain't got a tongue foret about it
I'm you know do you have fun in
Philly I gotta be free yeah they
got a $20 tequila when do I drink never
the frozen margarita in
Philly for 20 bucks it's got to be like
32 now but just pay for it and look the
other way do to get you drunk I'm not
going to lie to you you know my
tolerance I don't even drink it's just a
refreshing drink when it's 900
degrees in Philly and they got the best
wet ice whatever they they call it
water ice oh really he sat 30
feet from the stand so I was like a
yo-yo when I left there I was all
sugared up on the ice you know
what I'm saying but right now I'm
starting to feel good I had my
little siles mushroom here
oh flavor you got
tonight I got milk chocolate you
know what I'm saying nice tremendous I
love it and I gotta give them a free
plug because they always take good care
Uncle Joey if you're in the mood for
some sillies here the sill sibon
chocolate four grand bars the milk
chocolate go to fungi Factory on
Instagram put in Uncle Joey Savage all
one word I don't know where it's lower
case or higher
case you know what I'm saying you want
cases watch La
order I'm sorry about the lighting
tonight I'm experimenting I'm not doing
a remake of the monsters I just got to
figure this out there you go that's a
little bit more staer now I look more at
home I changed it up a little bit I
moved the room this way Lee I got the
picture you gave me out of
respect Taylor to my right glad you like
it I got the book to my aunt top of me
which don't forget the book signing
tomorrow Wednesday yeah tomorrow night
6: to8 and Pur you're not going to walk
in there like some Johnny CHD let me
shake your hand with you know
and then over here you got lead Zeppelin
from my left who's better than me I got
Lawrence Taylor on my right Leed
Zeppelin to my left I got Charles
Bronson under him I got my record player
right here Fro Cocker you know what I'm
saying I love it for a commercial
break here let's take a breather from
yak yak listen it's getting cold
out there but the games are heating up
basketball is Back Jack and DraftKings
an official sports betting partner of
the NBA has an unbeatable offer for
checkin listeners only you ready for
this you could score 200 instantly in
bonus bets by throwing down just $5 on
the NBA Joey what are you talking about
that's $200 on a Tuesday coming at you
so you have a little NBA cash for
yourself
make things even more exciting with
Draft Kings parlay string together
multiple bets from the same game or
build your paray across multiple games
for a shot at making a Payday even
better when was the last time you better
paray never It's Time to Get Down Jack
DraftKings has a lot going on right now
but basket mall is more fun when you're
right there watching the game jumping up
and down with your brothers download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now yeah
Preston Co Joey new customers can get
200 and bonus bets instantly for betting
$5 that's right Uncle Joey on a Tuesday
only at draftking sports book with code
Joey the crown is yours listen you got a
gambling P call 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net and New York
call one 8
8778 Hope New York or text Hope h o p n
y
467 369 I love you download the
DraftKings app we're back anyway
we were talking about the man in the
studio about when you work in an office
and you do dirty things there that
night listen I never worked in an office
yes I did I I think I did something for
a while in an office
I things I didn't even know how to go on
computer por and then or anything but
some by the desk it makes you want to
bang one out you know what I'm saying
well I saw a clip of you talking about
you did live in an office yeah but it
was it didn't have a desk like I wasn't
sitting at a chair like I got
now it was an office that was empty with
a carpet on the floor not even
it was a towel rolled up I lived like an
Indian guy in Bangladesh or
something like
that
okay Jesus Christ you didn't put a desk
in huh you didn't have to put a desk in
to like pretend I had something in there
I had like a 1800 number and something
else that's good enough where's your
desk I sit on the
floor better for my
back oh and did you ever bring a girl
back there list I'm 60 years old I'm
just saying when I was young and you
were doing powder and you'd wake up
from Powder You' have different sexual
urges some bang went up somewhere you
know what I'm saying like you had like
the twitch from last night like I went
home and I gotta youever wake up
and you have like a a nut that's
swollen on the right side the left side
and you're like oh that hurts yeah it
hurts because you were thinking about
giving somebody a stabbing and you you
banged one out but you fell
asleep yeah oxygen went in but it didn't
shoot out now you're walking around with
a limp you don't know what it is until
you bang down also you're like
a Eureka
Eureka look at you with that beard you
like alib Baba sucker no no no not huh I
you always used to say I had Isis beard
I'm not I'm not what are you talking
about a comeback but you know they're
still not going deep I think they took
that Starbucks money and they were like
you know what we're g to chill right
here we'll shoot arrows at each other
we'll bomb each other that's even better
at the price they're paying us who gives
a poo and they
just it's like you new
catchphrase
whato just for tonight you know what I'm
saying if you said that after every joke
after what after every joke you just
said f oh my God something just hit me
hold on give me a minute to catch my
oxygen where's the water and where's the
ice bag I got water the water in I think
the water's in your
hand I gotta tell you about the best
time I had last week
okay for you guys that are at home I I
don't do much I go to my daughter's
softball games I play Bachi which we got
beat up last Tuesday we went deep into
the night with them we took them into
the murky Waters but they were
talented as and we got beat 11 to6
so we're done on Tuesday nights we ended
up two and 13 or two and 16 or something
like that but it got me out of the house
on Tuesday nights you had fun start and
and it was in my mind it wasn't about
taking pictures or jumping up and down
I'm just one of you
getting away from my wife for an hour
and a half that's it this is what it is
if you think I'm gonna come here and
practice and talk about strategies I got
to do I got a 10 year old
so that ended Tuesday night and I was
sad Tuesday night I really was Lee I
came home and I was like what am I
going to do on Tuesday now so I called
the guys I go let's just go bowling on
Tuesdays let's eat some shrooms
and let's go bowling on Tuesday
right these guys are all in they're my
dogs right
so we planned on it I don't know where
we're going to go tonight so
uh Friday my wife had something with
mercy and I was like kind of
coming back from somewhere and I got
home and she's like you're on your own
tell about fck 8:30 or something
like that and then I have something in
the refrigerator not eat on your own I
wasn't really that hungry I had been
I got to Jiu-Jitsu I had to meet
somebody I was in the car for like two
hours it was one of those days we were
stopping at yellow lights you know those
people you stoping yellows to irritate
you like stoping the yellow really
with a BMW you're stop the
yellow why are you doing this to me why
did you buy this car why today
again I'm trying to do things
and I get behind you know a you
know $ 200,000 $300,000 car and they're
doing the speed limit about a week ago I
got behind one of those tester
Roes 9 North this
was doing below the speed limit oh no he
wouldn't let me around him man and a
brand new tester and I'm like why are
you being such a douchebag and I
finally got around them you know me dog
you either let me go I'm gon to smash
into that tester Roa and I and I
got Geico that hurt my feelings
I got GE what what are you gonna hit me
about now I don't want to
hear from you right now I'm busy I'm
busy I'm doing a podcast
anyway what's up
moo oh I'm sorry yeah what was the you
said you had like a great time so Friday
night I'm my wife she calls me B
I just got back I you know what let me
wash my monkey let me take a shower
change clothes my I've been
driving for two hours I got I took a
shower after Jiu-Jitsu now I'm fresh
again and again I'm got to take wash my
mouth oh was
raining that's what it was and I'm like
I took a shower I was sitting here
also my brother called me the crazy guy
The Fish Guy
right I love him to death I've been here
for three years but our schedules just
don't
match up he has to go to work he
getss up at 3: in the morning
he's in his truck at 4: to head to
Brooklyn to get fish at the fish
market up
there I would shoot myself and
trust me there's a lot of nights where
I've got up to piss at 3: in the morning
and I go I go meet my brother Chris
and take a ride get some clams
at cost and like this right
so something I don't know if he called
me I called him he was at this bar where
a girl that we went to high school Works
she runs the bar so he's like come over
they have what you like they have this
uh escarole and beans it's like all
right beautiful so I drive it's
like a 30 minute drive I thought
it was 10 minutes away it was raining it
was dark there's curves there's
deer you know it's deer season
there's little deers everywhere they're
everywhere you think it's I mean tiny
ones they're babies and if you know
they're around around the parents are
around so you might hit one of them or
they might run into you so you got to
drive with caution you know so I
had already popped a couple mushroom
chocolates so I was out there in
the car listen to The Song
Remains the Same I was rocking in that
listening to uh no quarter
whole lot of love it was tremendous I
was seeing lights and I'm like wow
this is tremendous and I went to where
he was at he was he had been there since
1:00 a.m. afternoon pounding doubles
like a Savage that he is 65 years old
God bless him and his nose was leaking
that's why I love him he never gave up
I'm a he never gave up he went
straight for the jackpot 60 five
and he still does it all weekend
till Sunday morning and Monday he's
delivering fish running his own business
like a soldier he only works three days
a week he works
Tuesdays Wednesdays and Fridays
he gets off at 11: in the morning he's
done by 11: it's his own business he
does what the he wants he already
has his customers he's had them for 40
years is
1980 he knows a lot about fish so he
invites me over there I go over he's
shitfaced right and he is
hysterical the last time I saw him I
drove him to a
funeral my friend's mother died and we
both grew up with her and I said the
only way I'll go is if I drive with
somebody because I was getting the dizzy
spells okay time from my
ears and uh I drove him to the
funeral before the funeral we went to
eat at
Rudy's all right now I got a bowl of
soup I got a salad you know maybe uh a
dozen clams a half water gamar whatever
with the medium sauce he starts drinking
doubles
before this
week so by the time we get up to
leave I don't have to tell you and he's
hilarious he just says and if
there's powder he goes off the
rail 64 years old at the
time so well we're already leaving
Rudy's it's two: in the afternoon I want
to get there the Wake opened up at like
1 or two I'm there like a 210 2:15 and
be out of there by 3:15 to beat the
track going south he lives two blocks
from me right
so by the time we get to the wake he's
up right so I brought like Edibles with
me and when I went to the bar with him
some guy recognized me and he came up to
we started talking and this guy had some
great Edibles and we started trading he
was at Rudy's and we started trade
little Edibles and he gave me a
50 and like a 10 and like a 15
right so you know what's coming I just
love that it's in awake too I had
already bombarded myself with
all the Edibles I brought the guy gave
me except for those last three but he
was there when the guy gave him to me
right so boom you know he's at the Wake
he's already going off on the Communist
you know who Ked John F Kennedy he asked
one I have a friend that doesn't have a
stomach right
and he owns a restaurant hysterical he's
owned the restaurant for 80
years he doesn't have a stomach he's got
a funny name I don't want to out
him on here but a bunch of us know him
and my friend's ex-husband we went up
and he goes you're starting to look like
that guy out the stomach and he goes
I'll kick you the ass right in
the Wake was just classic and all a
sudden my friend looked at me and she's
like it's time to take him home so we
get in the car he's lit
he's got white in him he's got
12 drinks he's talking nonsense we get
on the turn pack he goes hey I know that
guy gave me those Edibles give me the 10
so I dropped the 50 on him right oh I
dropped the 50 on him as
[Music]
we it's Tuesday night tuck I hit
the oh that's tremendous oh the 50
oh I hit the I hit him with a 50 by the
time we were on Route three right by the
time we hit the park where he's
in the car like two beers and he's got
two waters I took two Waters from the
Wake they were on the table and I kept
one I put one in the middle in case he
wanted it you know I'm taking little
sips the Edibles are hitting me I'm
trying to ignore that he ate the 50 I
can already see that it's
rocking his world he's thinking about
his family and where he went wrong
and what color the fish should be I mean
this
guy is a riot I can't take him out in
public you cannot take him out in public
because he just say and and you're
saying that I take him out because I
gotta be honest with you it's
entertainment I love this family growing
up I grew up in this
house you know uh how can I kick
him in the stomach everybody died I'm
all he's got left from the old days so I
thought it would be nice I go into this
place I he's hammered he comes over he
kisses me 10 times I'm so happy you came
I love you you know
over and over but again I've heard it
for 50 years you know I knew him
since 51st Street him and his family we
went up to 85th Street I was always in
their house in fact I lived with them
before I was homeless and 80
three I mean you know I know these
so I sat there with him for two hours
and just I drank water with lemon and
watched Houston make a comeback and I
didn't eat anything but he asked me to
take something home that he wanted me to
eat I had already eaten here I had
something that was my wife had
made but those two three hours
like I got there at 7:30 and by 9ine I
was taking him
home and he was up but hold on
the day he ate the edible we're driving
he's I can see he's really looking
around SP what's going on and he's
asking me all these questions about like
and I just ignore him and he'll keep
talking he'll just keep talking SP ha
she sucked my dick in the mouth and then
he'll say something else to me his wife
don't even want him
around J like he goes here answer the
phone it's jod his girlfriend I looked
at the messages they were all from her
you're not coming home tonight you're
going to sleep in the truck you you
were supposed to get me cigarettes and
come back it's 9:00 at night you were
coming back at
1:30 he's a riot listen when people say
to you oh I did this I party out listen
if you met this guy at his age I don't
care how old you are this guy shamed you
he doesn't do it Coast to
Coast okay what does that mean got the
control of a Catholic okay that
means Sunday
at lunchtime he cuts it off whether he's
snor and Coke whether he's smoking it
whatever the he's doing he cuts it
off and he sleeps he's got Monday
off so Monday about 6 he comes back to
life he cooks takes a shower and he's
normal and he'll ask me questions when I
say to that's what I spend like he's
but again I you know when you
you don't walk away from somebody I I
get him and I know I'm the last person
that he's got
so you know we we said goodbye he was
torturing some woman he was torturing
some guy you know but again they
know him and he's been going in there
for 10 years buying everybody drinks
they threw him out of uh where we got
the pot Ro sandwiches they threw him out
they threw him out there he's 86 I even
asked man anything we could do to bring
him back and they're like listen he
comes in here on a Friday he
spends a lot of money but next thing you
know he sit on some woman's lab
breathing out
can't have
that I was gonna say what do you do to
get kicked out of a pot roast place but
oh my God it's like that remember I took
you that did we not go there for a pot
roast sandwich you put horseradish on it
with a I think smoking jack next time
you come down that's where we'll go no
names The Brass Rail it's great I love
the
best prime rib I've ever
had I was there about two Saturdays ago
I hadn't been there for like a year you
know how much do I eat prime rib not
never right never it's not like but
every once in a while you're like you
know what Papa the weather's starting to
toughen up a little bit it's time to a
little prime rib you got a
little once a year guys don't worry
about me oh you know I know people
eating meat every hour
and they're like I'm healthy okay check
back with me in 10 years when your
veins are coming out of the
eyeballs and you look like a
cow all the cow things you
did
you don't know what you putting in your
mouth today no oh it's I saw a video I
don't care what supermarket you're going
unless you're buying it on the farm and
you know the dude you don't know
what you're putting in your mouth you
come to terms with that every time you
eat a piece of meat you pray for the
best have you ever gone to it like
gotten it delivered from a farm do they
have that in Jersey they have it up here
it's great you know i' like to just I'd
like to get like a brochure like a
you know I'm an old man i' like to get
like a website and maybe visit it you
know if they want to sell me the cow and
cut it up and funnel it to me throughout
the year make me I know my my
brother-in-law is part of his service
that you paid them in January and they
give you the whole thing but
they they give you like 17 pounds of
hamburger meat in h patties 10 more
loose if you want to make spaghetti
sauce ribs whatever if the cow has rib
whatever the cow has or the pig that's
what you get but they cut it up
nice for you if you want it they'll send
it out quarterly to you and if you don't
you could pick it up in one shot
whatever the it's like that thing
that they used to sponsor us Blue Apron
no not that thing the other
one the Meat Company when they first
came out oh butcher box butcher box bro
butcher box is not a bad service at all
they don't sponsor me I'm just telling
you people I have a friend around the
corner
Steve brother Steve always has Primo
meat I don't know what he subscribed to
this that they send them Wings they send
them F you see the wings they send you
they ain't no HIV California wings those
are real chicken wings 100% da
steroid chickens you eat a pound of
those things within 10 years you'll be
growing
something something a lump out of your
neck out of your eye those wings ain't
just good they're coming back
somewhere trust me I eat those
too if I'm up in Buffalo
you know that I can't St you that good
they're really good but yeah you
made me hungry oh
yeah what's multiple Waters yeah you
know me I'm dehydrated I pop I only pop
three but it's time to maybe pop six
what do you think it's night I only got
a couple errands tomorrow tomorrow's a
light day Wednesday I got the books
exciting that's gonna be fun those are
really fun listen I want people to know
this opinion I got I just got a
whatever I'm not dumb it's October 20
4th today the actors Union is supposed
to all the actors junion whoever the
is following it you know for some
pre reason honest to Godly I get 10 of
these emails every week and some of them
are actors some of them are
people who just want to know the truth I
don't know what they're fighting
for I they don't want artificial
intelligence listen here's where I'm I'm
not trying to be selfish I look at
artificial intelligence ain't nobody
make no AI of me you can't turn me into
Elvis on a good day no matter what you
do AI eii you whatever the you
want to do I'm still Uncle Joey you want
to use my you know I guess it's
going to ruin the
future you know I guess it's supposed to
with with the actor salary guys we
chose you chose a business not not
everybody wants to do it takes a lot to
do that business and at one point you
have to see where you really are and
maybe if you want to act there's always
theater in New York City there's always
a local theater in Pittsburgh I know
there's got to be something going on in
wer that's a big theater Town huge so it
doesn't bother you to like think about
like them like putting you in movies or
like stuff like that like you don't get
like not be stupid that's where it's
going anyway I understand that you're
battling that but these people are
holding on to that is what I'm
saying they're not just they're gonna
leave a clause in there and experiment
and in the meantime you're gonna get
from a different direction they
already got attorneys trying to figure
out the next
move right that's what they do you know
they won't give up that move until they
have something down the pipe that the
martians brought them and now
they don't have it so they have it's
it's crazy it's crazy where you're at my
heart goes out to people that are just
actors this is hundred and
something days this couple
months right now with you know we're a
month away from eating turkey and
thanking God for the year we had what
about these people I did my best
you know they wrote me a little
thing an amp thing and I donated to the
amp thing usually I throw those
envelopes away but this year dog I know
what's going on right now I don't know
how much of that money they'll get you
know but at least you feel good about
yourself you know right no but you have
to I
mean that it must be crazy like to like
because
then is it serious like let's say like
you were a union actor and like someone
was trying to bypass the strike and you
did it would you like get barred from
ever act like would that be like a big
deal I imagine it'
be here's I look at
it I saw people during the strike early
on that already had the SAG thing on the
fist they were you
know but to be honest you meanwhile
they're cooking on a a plan to
go back to work one of those vouchers or
whatever they're talking
about and two people did reach out to me
and I was shocked that one person did I
don't know them personally they just
said if I'd be interested to shoot this
thing it's nonunion blah blah blah blah
blah and I'm like I'm a felon okay I'm a
I try to be the best American I
can I don't hit a squirrel on the street
you know I don't
Litter I piss on the street from time to
time 60 sometimes I gotta go when I
gotta go I even have a bottle in my car
I try real
hard dump to piss out in the street I
try to piss and me I'll take it listen
I'll take my own piss to 7-Eleven and
dumping in the garbage but I won't take
I won't pick up dog poo and walk at home
like those dudes and talk toi I
don't want to talk to you you got you
know what I'm saying you have a kiss of
death right now I'm trying to bet
uh something the World Series
you're walking up to me a little bag of
with a smile in your face if I had
to walk around with a bag of I
wouldn't have no smile on my face I'd be
looking at that dog like wait this is
this is life oh this is life I gotta
walk out here at 6:30 in the morning for
you to take a that looks bigger
than mine and then if you have a
Chihuahua one of those little lap dogs
ever smell their little dynamites it's a
little got piece of this big
inch it looks like one of those milky
Duds whatever they call them
does oh I can't every one of those again
oh my God milky D what the they are
something those little those dogss smell
like death they smell like death
I love my cats but every once in a while
that little devil misses the
litter box you walk out through a fog of
debt you understand me you got to take
the litter box out hit it with gasoline
lightting on fire you know it's a
stink that Henry hell couldn't
even take out of his truck it was that
bad Henry oh what's that smell I hit a
skunk no you didn't you had a C
that took a your
trunk this is why I E little I
don't even eat edibles during the week
no more yes you do listen if I eat like
Friday night 400 milligrams that's a
play
date that's me showing up and going hey
how you doing and next you know where he
go up in the bathroom no he didn't he's
on his bicycle headed down to Fairfax to
that blet show he's gone
who shot that dck you know what I'm
saying f
f look at you with that beard what are
you talking about you gotta sh every
time you go back I think Ali bab is
coming hey I want to remind you guys
this episode of the checkin is brought
to you by better help listen things are
stressful this time of the year we've
been living through a global pandemic
people are losing jobs left and right I
know how it feels sometimes sometimes
it's too much you just want to talk to
somebody boom there you go better help
is there what's better help Joey it's
designed to work with your busy schedule
just fill out the quick survey get match
with a licensed therapist and be on your
way to better mental health hoop doop
listen when I moved I had some
issues I didn't know what I wanted to do
what direction I want to do it better
help put me on the right path it lets
you get in touch with a therapist
through Zoom calls on the phone by
message FaceTime listen whatever works
for you all right if you don't mesh with
the first therapist no problem problem
we'll switch at any time for no
additional charge no questions asked so
do me a favor right now listen a lot of
things are going on make your brain your
friend with better help b t t r help hlp
one word visit betterhelp.com
Diaz D AZ and and visit them today and
listen what Uncle Joey's throwing in I'm
going to get you 10% off your first
month and guess what you're going to
love better help that's betterhelp
hp.com Diaz thank you for
listening oh my god oh Jesus Christ Joey
mushroom shrimp
fart you had shrimp yeah because anyway
I was telling you about my brother Chris
so I was driving him home and on the way
home you know he was
like I don't care everybody heares me
talking about him everybody knows how
much I love him and
but on the way home I realized why I
picked him up because he was like half
drunk talking about you know yeah I went
to this
uh gang bang in 82 everybody was
doing BL you know I don't know what he's
talking about he talks to me about the
10th mafia families like I said I just
put the music on higher but to get back
to the story on the way home that time
with the Edibles by the time we hit the
parkway he was acting weird and he
started looking around the car right I
didn't know what he was looking for he
was looking for the bottled water that
he stole from Rudy an hour before awake
and we left awake I'm sorry Lee right in
front of me I'm already kicking with the
Edibles I just want to get him out of
the car but I love him okay I'm not
gonna kick him out if this is anybody
else I'd pull over and just fck leave
him at the side of the road but I know
this guy a long
time so he's looking at me all creepy
and all a sudden he sees where the water
is hidden he gets the waterly he opens
up the bottle and he just pours it all
over and his shirt is wet and I'm
dying right so I drop him off I
gave him like a 50 and then I gave him a
he goes what's that in there I go just
10 he goes give me the 10 so I gave him
60 I gave him 60
milligrams I drop him off I forget all
about it right he already put the water
on himself I
gave
I wanted to do that before I gave him a
paper
towel I took him
home now this guy goes to bed at nine
o'clock at night right not even not even
he cooks eats dinner and he's
nappy Noo-noo time by 8:30 like
right now if I call him he's
out I get a call from him like at 10
o'clock and he's like Jesus
Christ what was in those things I just
ate an apple pie and a turkey I
can't stop eating and I go it's going to
be all he goes I don't know and he hangs
up and next morning he calls me again
he's like I can't go to work because of
you I'm still up what was in that
I want to buy more he's telling me all
this
well
anyway Friday I took him
home I go back a long time and how we
all met because he had a family he had
two other brothers
one of them being the notorious bonehead
rest in peace oh I didn't know
that and I know what he went through
with bonehead I know what he went
through with me and bonehead I know what
he went through with me bonehead and
Kurt so both of them are gone now rest
in peace the mom is gone now who was
like my mom she's gone now so on the way
home at one point he's like I miss my
brothers thank you for showing up you're
my brother brother I gave him a
kiss we pulled in front of the house he
was talking about some Japanese
restaurant and he goes hold on I got
something for you he gave me a five
pound bag of clams that are
beautiful oh nice he gave me a bag of
these shrimp remember the time I
almost choked at that hotel yeah Vegas
with the big shrimp and I had to
do the H lick John John salami was there
yeah are bigger wow shrimp
cocktail she made three shrimp we had to
split them how big I love shrimp
oh yeah me too put some
horseradish in that and
that cocktail sauce you you
know and he gave me uh something
else crab so that's why my wife cakes
today yeah and then next called him are
you okay he don't remember nothing what
time did you pick me up what time did
you get there how much did I spend you
know he's he's the best he's the
best guys he's like still at it I'm not
talking about concerts or jumping up and
down or being on a
yacht this guy owns a successful
Fish Company he works his own
hours and he uh you know he's a
guy from the
neighborhood got a house
gorgeous a pool in the backyard this is
the reason I moved down here CU When I
used to come visit him in 999 I used to
come to this area and go holy
you're 45 minutes away from the
city that changed it's 55 from
where we grew up now and then another
you gotta add another 15 another hour
20 till the drive over the
Bridge yeah it's f
um two things got comedy okay but the
first thing I thought we'd talk about
that was great if you go to my old
podcast which I hated the
joint I did do an episode about
Comics not uh this is the year of
this is before any of movies
were released I was really upset
because Comics don't do TV like they
used to you know when I was a kid I grew
up watching Comics which was a rare hope
for a guy like me going wow someday not
me but maybe I'll do four episodes of a
show right when I'll just tap out I'm
good to go I was on a show everybody
wants me to jump up and down and hang
out with
kiss it's not what I want to
do what we talking
about yeah I don't know you said
something you want to talk about comedy
that used to be comedi on TV I saw the
new Bill Bird movie Old D yeah I want to
see that it got destroyed but I didn't
give a I'm gonna give Bill Burr a
chance I enjoyed it
the same way Joe Bill bur's comedy
listen there's a gift to do comedy then
there's a gift to bring your comedy to
the stage I'll always love the king
that's Tim Allen Tim Allen always
brought his comedy to the stage I don't
know how much of Red Fox comedy
went
into you know sord and Son but Tim Allen
took his career and did
Seasons off two hour specials
for Showtime maybe another 20 minutes he
did it
perfectly when you watch this bill bur
movie I enjoyed it I watched one time
with my by myself the first time right
when it came out the afternoon it was
raining and then the next night me and
my wife watched it again I do I watch
anything bills in except the Mandalorian
I don't like Star
Trek is in I'm talking in you know
anything he's in the one with uh
whatever from draft day I don't know the
name of the movie the guy from
uh Montana the show in Montana with oh
um
Yellowstone he did a movie with him I I
love bill I love Bill and anything I'm a
bill guy when Bill comes to town my wife
and me go and I'd rather sit in the
audience and watch it so I see
him I could sit through for some reason
yeah Chappelle with 20 comments that's
too much for Uncle Joey it's loud in
there people are dancing you know looks
like fun for me if I was 20 years ago
but 20 years ago I would walk on that
stage I'd be all half up
the night before I would fall apart like
uh velvet revolving four to Pieces
anyway who gives a about that how's
the going sucker it's
going it's going pretty well I just know
some people when out to see you I want
to thank them for going out and
supporting Lee sayat oh thank you this
is not Madison Square Garden these
aren't Studio 54 these uh open mics in
Boston and you guys go out there and it
means the world to me when he calls me
at night I wish I could I knew the
technology to tape him you have to hear
his voice the only thing you could do
better for him is licking his balls and
maybe cooking them dumplings Chinese
style I mean he sounds so happy happy
when he says to me dog and people came
out from the checkin and I'm like wow
I've been gauging this just to see and
I've been right
listen you don't want 200 people there
right but you know your mom's busy your
brother's doing jumping jacks I'm over
here ain't nobody going these open mics
for you and one of the best thing about
open mics is taking a friend to watch
you
bomb drive you home in the car you have
to start doing that somebody likes you
come on come watch me do an open mic
yeah I'm funny I'm thinking of doing a
tour with Jackie gleon tell him
something just to get him to your show
and take a call with him that's a
complete different type of confidence
that you gain there when a loved one
goes with you and you eat a bag of dicks
not your girlfriend somebody you work
with an uncle that you like you take him
for a steak and then make him sit
through 10 minutes of your and Open
Mic surrounded with people with lice and
people with mental problems and
those are people who love you dog and
when you buy them it's a really weird
talk you know it's a weird talk for them
and you want to be honest with them so
you don't tell them what do you think
I'm better than Dave Chappelle you know
who the you are but that's crazy
like I've had people come out and I bomb
and then they don't want to talk to me
after they talk to me before but not
after but I can't imagine being stuck in
the car with them on the way home
can you imagine like your neighbor let
me go down with you yeah I went there
years ago now it's completely
different to Joint you know he walks in
there with you and the next thing you
know you're on stage and it's an open
mic and then mind I don't know where
they're going and what they expect to
see but by you going there your
percentages are bombing if they have
music who goes in front of you guy with
the ukulele hold on one second anybody
got a gun let me shoot myself let me
just stick that's the open mic headliner
put a hat out and give put a dollar in
there send it to my wife and my kids I
don't I don't I'd rather not follow a
guy with a
ukulele I've never had to do that oh my
God I can't like it is crazy there have
been a couple people who come out to
shows but there have been like a couple
people who came to the open mics which
we really appreciate but
it's I wouldn't I I feel like my my mom
up and letting them know bro there's
like Rogan has an old joke there's
nothing like your mom watching your bomb
you know what I'm saying oh that's wored
M catching you sucking a dick in the
closet when Joe used to do that joke
people would just die like a either wait
a second my mother called me sucking a
dick one time
or Christ why you gotta put your mother
into this people get
offended I bet the comics died that's a
funny joke B how is the comedy you feel
going for you you know what I got I feel
like I got um we want to feel what
you're going through yeah to be
honest I I went through like a really
good period And I haven't bombed like
I've bombed like hard before I haven't
like
bombed but the last couple haven't been
like I haven't felt like I've done the
best and like the last one was really
fun but I
didn't I didn't know if I was hosting or
not and then I hosted and I just it's a
completely different like the guy who
hosts at the club in Foxboro is like a
great like a ton of energy get the crowd
into it and I didn't do I didn't really
do that and I had an okay set but they
just I felt like I didn't do like do the
right thing as a host so I was kind of
bummed out about it for a couple
days um but overall it's been pretty
good it's just like the last couple
shows have not been my
favorite I always
I don't know where and where Le you know
I don't know when and where somewhere I
got asked the host one night could it it
started somewhere in the Seattle area
and I ate a bag of dick and I went home
I was cracked because other people were
there maybe the club owner auditioned me
maybe it was a Booker it was something
like that it
wasn't Liv a die situation it was a job
I wanted and I ate a bag of dick and
they called me back and I hosted and I
died you know and I didn't blame it on
the audience I didn't blame it on her
she called me years later I just wasn't
ready to host I was a midlife feature I
was starting to Blossom from 20 minutes
and she asked me to host for 10 minutes
it was the most awkward thing I ever did
yeah and then you know that's why
working at a commercial Club it pains my
heart what they make the MC go up then
do he does three minutes and then
there's a this guy's coming this guy and
they make you do the whole lineup for
the whole year listen what the
guy do is flow this is a comedy club
they didn't come here to hear they got
three drinks in them it's October
they're like don't forget December 8th
it's the
funny you know what come on it's Friday
we got this much attention this poor
MC's going up there to basically be a
billboard right so he doesn't
really know but he's learning that if he
does it and he does 50% they don't give
a because they know that's torture
and they want somebody in that I'll go
I'll do it you know and then all a
sudden you show up to that now you're
doing eight weeks as an MC and at the
end of those eight weeks you'll go wait
a second I learned a different muscle
yeah and you learn the muscle of
control you learn how to go hey
how about a round of applause Lisi
waiting in the back but hold on did I
talk to you about the time
I got nasal sprayed it
was and boom now you have a closer you
have a three minute closer you Ain
strong and you don't go up there and go
all right real quick I about a shout out
to the weight staff give them two drinks
listen you want to come back to the club
you got to give the way staff a lot of
love if you sound like a robot
as an MC they ain't making no money
either
right just beg for them and you don't
don't forget to tip the host how about
giving them a round of applause and
that's it no how about a round of
applause for the MC's for the waitresses
the weight staff the people in the
kitchen and don't forget to tip them
it's Tuesday night everybody wants a
little Nookie cookie on a Tuesday night
you know and then there's two waitress
up front put a name to them right you
want now instead of having two people go
they don't like you're GNA have one
person go I didn't like isach you're
gonna have sis waiters go I don't know
about you but I made $100 because of him
because he said look at this girl with
the earrings she needs money for a kid
look it's a Fu it's a if you go
up there and go give her money I want to
take her home later you just being a
idiot right know her name before
you go up there and don't go for the
hottest chick and try to be
Johnny Suave go for the single
mom that got four kids at home the
Grandma's watching the kids and she's
doing this you could tell she's been
there she's a little weathered get her
name first and then work downhill and
pick two other ones or pick the guy he's
got purple hair boom don't go up there
and go look at her titties I want to
tit dog I saw
that times oh my God yeah yeah
I saw
that did it ever work
tell a chick that on a Thursday night
when you just got to the
club I want you to think of that
perspective unless you're doing
blow or doing something crazy why are
you telling the waitress she got
big tit for right in front of 200 people
is that what you
want how about Leo sayat he's got a
little dick flick tried to suck his dick
I had you know get a toothpick
whatever the fu
no that's awful okay I saw all those
little things as a host you're a
positive Source you're going out you're
the first they seeing
number one this is rough for you have a
little life to you I know it's rough to
just go up there I know you got the suit
with the sneakers on haa that's not a
host a host is somebody
that welcomes me welcome to the
hell ho I don't give a if they shot
the place up in still blood behind you I
don't care even if there's still
blood behind you and there's fly you
ever get to a comedy club and there's
blood outside with candles you you ain't
a comic unless you did that the dog
gu checking for IDs there's a
candle
spot you talked to George Perez we all
had a club in fact I told you a couple
weeks ago I bumped into my friend's wife
she just got out of jail after doing 90
days and she still had the bracelet on
she was in there for a comedy night this
was a buck wild Comedy Club
coers Jesus
Christ I also went to see the daero
movie with uh
whatever with uh said that was good it
was 30 minutes 45 minutes long for a lot
of people don't like that anytime you
talk to me about Indians I love
it okay whether they killed your uncle
or you killed them I want to hear the
Saga I don't want to just see a
bunch of Savages shoot each other that's
why I really enjoy the outlaw Josie
Wales I love Clint Eastwood but I love
those Indians and how they
portrayed themselves as
Savages no I haven't seen that in a long
time I have to go watch that again I was
saying that was something about it's
also M it's time for you to tick tock
and get the training I don't
see you you know and every week I check
on you well I had to go to church I had
to drive home you know that's it said
enough you're 32 years old whatever the
you are how old are you now me 35
all right then get it together you
should you know but yeah I had to drive
home from the show I still took 60
million listen you know they don't know
nothing your numbers your percentages
are getting low your L numbers are
getting low anyway I got a book signing
tomorrow night it's gonna be great I got
a lot of family people I got a
lot of North Bergen people coming down
so thank you for coming down don't
forget purchases required we're g to
have a lot of savages there with stories
remember you stole my crabs one time
they I don't want to hear this guys
what do you got going on this week
tarano same night Wednesday night off
the rails in Worster 8 o'clock I have a
fun show a bunch of great comics from
the Worcester in Massachusetts area I'm
doing like 30 minutes I'm really
excited all right well I want to thank
you guys I want to thank DraftKings in
better help and now for a word for my
sponsors
[Music]
guys Babble listen it's a new year I
know who cares but you can make a
resolution whenever you want this fall
instead of jumping up and down with your
friends on
Sundays try learning a new language they
have quick Techni lessons so you won't
get bored you'll be able to start
speaking a new language in as little as
three weeks so you can sound smart at
the Christmas party okay listen I know
you only got a GED but this is easy okay
you want to learn another language it's
important why because it's kind of
analytical at no listen you're never too
old to learn Chinese I'm thinking about
it right now I got to take time I gotta
hang out with Lee you know how it goes
but anyway bab lessons are designed by
over 150 language experts so you're
getting the real deal one study even
found that using Babel which just 15
hours was the same as taking a full
semester of a college language course
where you gonna get that you just
sitting there at home like a moo
anyway so do me a favor here's the
special limited time only listen you got
a nephew you got a cousin you know he's
having a hard time Bo get him a Babel
subscription I'm going to get you 55%
off what are you talking about 55% off
anybody can give you 50 Babel wants you
to learn a language they know what's
going to come down but only for our
listeners at babel.com
joeey Joe y That's 55% off at
b. Joey I've been telling people for
years you got to learn two or three
languages I know like eight languages
all right I used to be a Cuban James
Bond anyway